mesdames et messieurs le vainqueur fut
coton de te revoir
il est temps pour toi de défendre ton
titre lors d'un nouveau combat pas moi
ou du passera le reste de ta vie en
prison je te présente monk est un
spécimen d'humains supérieur plus grand
plus fort que n'importe quel être humain
sur cette plaine
ça arrivera pas il faut qu'on trouve un
moyen de faire avancer les choses
ils ont kidnappé ta femme il faut que tu
commences à t'entraîner
l'homme le plus fort ne gagnent pas
toujours le plus intelligent 6
la force contre sa faiblesse
et sa faiblesse c'est une bonne question
et te suffira de tasses mois
et de profiter du voyage
les chiens
interrompu ma méditation ça t'aide à
rester calme tirez pas